ciao ragazzi ben tornato in una puntata
di cucina buttata soprattutto bentornato
all'interno della mia cucina di merda
oggi siamo qui riuniti per celebrare il
funerale del buon gusto
l'ex premier neozelandese com'è che si
chiamava il english già un nome che non
voglio in alcun modo analizzare ha ben
pensato di mettersi ai fornelli
quando secondo me ancora premier e
creare questa pizza obrobriosa e orrida
un istinto che l'ha portato a diventare
ex presidente neozelandese è anche e
soprattutto una pizza con sopra degli
spaghetti in scatola che noi ci siamo
procurati ragazzi infatti abbiamo già
chiamato un prete esorcista dopo
pervenire a purificare questa casa nel
caso in cui dovessi ricevere visite
notturne dal maligno dicevo ha deciso di
mettere questi sopra e poi lei un ananas
a buffo sono tornate le ricette del
merito questa prima è tanto la smetta
che vuol dire che perfetta per questa
pizza de mer partiamo con gli
ingredienti per fare sta pizzo de merda
avremo bisogno di pasta della pizza già
fatta perché non ci abbiamo minimamente
voglia di sprecarci 4 pomodori innocenti
ingiustamente sacrificati per tale
abominio fette di prosciutto che
speravano di essere buttate nella
spazzatura ma in realtà finiranno su
questa pizza formaggio italiano
utilizzato nella maniera meno italiana
possibile cipollotti per coprire il
sapore un ananas che se tonfi calcio non
era meglio e infine il vero ospite di
questa giornata gli spaghetti con sosa
gis e se vedete c'è scritto con un
intero pomodoro spremuto dentro e che
cazzo c'erano spreme dentro continuiamo
abbiamo degli spettatori che sono venuti
a vedere questo abominio valentina fatti
sentire tu stai davvero per aprire
quella cosa
valentino oggi se sia implicato di
vestirsi allora sono messe tipo mostro
non può essere indovina chi l'ha
assaggerà visto che oggi per cose care
perché
ma che dici ma grazia tu pensi che il
tuo stipendio ti venga dato perché sei
bravo in qualcosa esatto due assaggi
pizze di merda con quello stipendio per
assaggiare nessuna vittima
nella merda diana sopra a una domanda
tutti i pregi quindi di essere campana e
quindi la pizza
ma tu mangi la pizza solamente quella lì
fatta bene cosa penserà mozzarella di
bufala vista grafico ion
a me non piace ecco fuori di qua grazie
grazie a un aforisma tutta la campana la
pizza campagna per la mozzarella
ridicola o ragazzi io sento questo e
vedo poco questo partiamo subito dalle
basi quelle angolare quindi dovresti
fare la torta ma ne frega una volta che
abbiamo creato questa base andiamo a
condirla cos'è che viene messo per primo
col sugo che quindi gara cosa subito
eletto però è bene di tutte le scritte
ha inscritto così consenso enorme è lo
speriamo tutti che hai fatto delle
affermazioni importanti gianmarco
nightmare before christmas cartone
sopravvalutato ma non ti vergogni ha
fatto ancora direi un lavoro sono detto
che un pochino sopravvalutato no fai
silenzio giammarco che seguì subito
graziana in campania 20 la vuole sapere
se questo tatuaggio la rende più sexy e
si si si
secondo voi è un tatuaggio sexy l'ha
chiesto sentì male io so che tu parli di
farci vedere se gli va bene
ecco i guanti da serial killer
assistente ok perfetto
inquietantissimo sono pure spezzati sono
tipo mini spaghetti v
ma quindi quelli sono più stand o
salsiccia siamo tornati agli incubi di
cucina
se sì ma qui ci stiamo superando l'odore
se potresti descrivere le tue mutante
vedrà pomodori stata c'è un pomodoro
emigrava sbagliare la mia lingua 12
mille costretto smette di parlare molto
meglio un tocco di freschezza riesce
bene a vedere il lato positivo in ogni
cosa però dai divertenti queste ricette
da no io adoro queste sono quelle più
divertenti in assoluto così massima io
cioè fosse per me cucina buttata giù è
mica si chiama cartoni aggiungiamo il
prosciutto lo sfiduciamo purtroppo non
sono riuscito a trovare quello tocchi
perché ci sarebbero andare quello pochi
mammamia peccato quindi non stiamo
rispettando la ricetta del maestro billi
english e la nostra pizza prende forma
una forma terribile ne metto altro però
vi posso dire all'energia che da fare
queste ricette quel brivido quel non
sapere se domani ti sveglierai è quella
roba lì camere cioè stasera tornerò a
letto dormiva in un lettino d'ospedale
proseguiamo con l'incubo che andiamo ad
affrontare lei che tra parentesi per
come se ne sono andati via le foglie
dovrebbe essere di una succosi notes e
come eventi ce n'è poca se no me rovini
la pista ma che il resto vi rendete
conto che per il bene di questo format
andiamo incontro a roba abominevole cioè
io costituirmi iscrivere a questo
chiamare la campagna notifiche metterei
un like
immaginatevi che bello poter dire a
cacchio assurdo che gli ho messo online
avrebbe detto che oggi nelle pagine di
cronaca nera lo avrei provato io così me
lo farei certo lo prendi dopo nella
pizza dunque la casa e scusami grazia
fatto manca un ultimo ingrediente
cipollino il cipollotto a me in realtà
casa troppo al respingimento che secondo
bonanni esco essere nemmeno disgustato
da questa cosa tagliamo quivi a questa
parte anche voi direte che cosa che
dobbiamo andare a prendere a questo
punto caro guglielmo da parte verde che
comunque è buonissima si scompongono e
sono ancora di più questi dell'anno
freschezza mettiamo all'interno del
forno avogradi perché mica ce lo dicono
ah boh tempo ma appena la vedrete
carbonizzata saprete che avrete comunque
fatto in quel caso il migliore qualora
dovesse dire alle fuori se fosse cotta
infiliamo richiamo non è pronta se non è
pronta alla crosta croccante sembrano
patate no quella è la nonna si ammala
meno severo il tuo cervello continua a
fare di tutto per eliminarlo è pronto
non facciamo i soldi assaggi green
screen ste cose cioè non se lo merita
quindi io direi di farci un assaggio è
un po umida lo lascia un po ad asciugare
il forno spento nel frattempo andiamo a
sistemare un minimo un angolino per fare
una degustazione di questa delicatezza
posiziona questo miracolo con in a
non vedi l'ora di assaggiarla guardare
mito dai anche io la mangia dico che fa
cacare il coraggio e tutto prosciutto in
tanti nel a te piace io sono un tipo lei
manco avessimo fatto mangiamo di gozzi
lei l'altra io sono molto spaventato ai
quindi tutti i treni vai vai dai un
altro bel morso
[Risate]
grazie alla sua è contenuta rivelata pro
moschea ricordato uno degli incubi del
passato
cosa vuol dire a bill english è stato
arrestato
purtroppo zelanda qua in italia con la
pena di morte se la caverebbe nuova
zelandia bocciata clamorosamente doccia
sebbene e qui la nostra campana doc
fatto le cose sito di vista potrà fare
dice sfociato promossa non classifica ma
si ficca abile neanche le bocciature
rimesso segue una cosa mi dà più
fastidio questa pizza questo ok si non è
la fine del mondo ma non è così
terribile sull'ananas sulla pizza
la ragazza alla pizza come bruto st
accelera cioè fare pd pugnala la boccia
sfociato poi bacco bocciati sim bocciata
ma se avessi molta fame riuscire a
trovare una gradevole avere con questo
che saltano bill english va a fare le
valigie perché non credo che potrò
andare tranquillo per le strade del
nostro stato meraviglioso trasmesso in
nuova zelanda mi candido come premi
avevamo già deciso che tra le varie
proposte che farò sarà un bel piatto
alla merd stand di una pizza e circa di
sopra quindi o un'area che mi aspetto
ragazzi iscritti a questo canale mattina
da camper e le notifiche mettete un bel
pollice in su noi ci vediamo giovedì
alle 14 con un nuovo video dei quali non
ci sarò perché sarò ormai a chilometri
di distanza da casa mia
ciao